mr. white the new heeey code chitra
welcome to McFarland this is a farming
town these are good kids smart kids they
just need a chance at a better future
I'm coach white your new PE teacher
alright run a lap
one another one you know that kid yeah
it's Tom spouts
you know how fast you were going what
are you a cop cuz you're running a mile
in five minutes so principal Camillo I
want to start a cross-country team
that's a private school sport we have
kids here who seem like they can run
forever and they pick an extreme heat
they go to school all day some of them
even run home I've seen it Jim let me
ask you something you've coached cross
country before no well they sound
perfect I think the guys would be in the
cross country for what to win to compete
nobody wins around here white don't have
to be that way I watched your run you
say you want to help me get a team
together six mile same page now she may
be do you guys keep going I'll time you
from here let's get it again
so I new commute you want to eat come on
ain't nowhere my niece yeah well then
you're running naked if we were you were
missing tower that my voice trained with
you is one hour they do not work with me
on sat nail you believe in yourselves we
could believe in your teammates you
won't matter what anyone else thinks
nice shorts dude yeah nothing you can't
do with that car and more Seattle secret
ever biggest hearts of ever seen
they come to the family huh no so y'all
don't say to me know how you gonna be
family if you know we think together huh
I want that back Oh slippy